quand vous pensez que j'ai la même au
repos comment ça va mes petits amis moi
ça va pas pire aujourd'hui on va se
mater le film seul sur Mars the marshion
en vélo troisième film de riple Scott
dont je parle sur cette chaîne après
alien et Blade Runner longtemps
m'avez-vous demandé de traiter de cette
œuvre au combien captivants
intrinsèquement passionnant et
compendieux prenons une vision
abermecienne et vespérale en
essentialisant l'exégèse d'un
syncrétisme dithyrambique de l'ataraxie
ça veut dire quoi tout ça seul sur Mars
c'est un film que je connaissais pas
très bien je l'avais eu qu'une seule
fois avant de le voir une deuxième fois
et pourtant c'est un film qui colle
tellement bien avec le thème de la
chaîne et le film
ça va c'est sympa mais c'est pas non
plus
je préfère plutôt coup de foudre à
Notting Hill quoi
je préfère quand même quoi qu'il en soit
nous allons parler de ce film qui rentre
dans la catégorie hard science un sous
genre de la science-fiction car c'est
dans lequel on fait de la science enfin
à peu près le dis c'est un film parfait
pour 12 par sec
mesdames et messieurs je suis très fier
de vous parler du nouveau sponsor de
cette vidéo car vous allez voir que ce
produit haut de gamme a complètement sa
place et une place de choix sur cette
chaîne sur mon bureau et peut-être aussi
sur le vôtre voilà
de novium rien que le titre j'ai
l'impression d'être dans l'espace j'ai
l'impression que c'est de la
science-fiction c'est mais non c'est
bien réel qui a dit qu'un stylo ne
pouvait pas être parfait le hooverpen
est ultra classe il est résistant il
défie des lois de la gravité il défie
Einstein en étant comme suspendu en
apesanteur cette gamme de stylo feront
partie de votre attends cette gamme
feront partie oui c'est bon des plus
beaux stylos qu'il vous sera donné de
tenir entre vos doigts il existe trois
modèles le classique édition en
aluminium ou en titanium un stylo très
charte très pur qui se maintient
parfaitement à la verticale et auquel
vous pouvez donner c'est pas un
mouvement circulaire quasiment infini
non et pas infini il y avait un moment
donné il va s'arrêter et quand il
s'arrête bah si vous voulez le refaire
tourner vous le refaites une fois avec
vos doigts j'ai dit pas très compliqué
est également disponible l'Inter stellar
éditionne en version standard en
plusieurs couleurs en or 18 carats ou
même avec un petit fragment de météorite
à l'intérieur rendez-vous compte du
niveau de classe de l'objet on est sur
de l'audace on est sur de la créativité
on est sur du spatial car pensez-vous
que son angle d'inclinaison de 23 degrés
virgule 5 a été fait au hasard mais
absolument non c'est un hommage à la
terre un autre terre elle-même inclinée
d'autant de degrés incliné de 25 degrés
tu es comme pour mars quoi ça m'aurait
arrangé pour la vidéo mais bon toujours
est-il que les créateurs ont reçu pour
ce produit le prix du magazine Time time
permettant l'une des meilleures
inventions de 2022 et enfin last but le
futur édition lover pain 3.0 incliné à
60 degrés disponible en roller et en
plumes et grâce à ses merveilleuses
productions vous pourrez vivre une
expérience d'écriture tout à fait
inédite en utilisant également le très
beau notebook que vous pourrez trouver
parmi les nombreux accessoires du site
regardez-moi ça quel est
souvent vu des films comme ça dans
l'histoire du cinéma car c'est un film
dans lequel chaîne bein ne meurt pas
possible quoi non parce que c'est clair
que quand on voit Sean Bean dans un film
on se dit tout de suite bon bah lui dans
trois semaines il est mort et ben voilà
bah c'est fou d'ailleurs c'est même un
des très rares blockbusters dans lequel
personne ne meurt et c'est très
certainement le seul film de Ridley
Scott dans lequel il y a zéro mort c'est
quand même pas rien dans une [__] seul
sur Mars c'est un film de
science-fiction très intéressant
puisqu'il se classe dans le sous genre
de la harpe science et oui dans les CF
il y a plein de sous genre il y a le
Space Opéra le post apocalyptique le
cyberpunk le Space fantasy lucrony le
steampunk le rétro futurisme le voyage
dans le temps la dystopie le bondage
science le hentai et le Hard science
hard ça y est mon préféré la harcèle
social et c'est un genre qui s'oppose un
petit peu à tous les autres parce que ça
se caractérise par une grande précision
scientifique la chaîne Youtube douce
parsec par exemple est à une chaîne de
Hard science les auteurs ils racontent
des histoires à partir de technologie et
de fait scientifique connu de leur
époque qui vont adapter au monde
futuriste qui crée mais en respectant
les connaissances admises et en
extrapolant un peu aussi pour que ce
soit encore plus cool mais de manière à
ce que ça reste crédible c'est-à-dire
que ce qu'on voit n'existe pas mais ça
pourrait peut-être exister un jour il
est peut-être même pas si lointain
d'ailleurs le meilleur exemple de Hard
science est bien sûr la saga Star Wars
exactement la même chose et donc
imaginer des missions spatiales futures
sur Mars à partir de la technologie
qu'on a déjà c'est exactement ce qui se
passe dans seul sur Mars la blé Scott a
vraiment une volonté de filmer mars de
la façon la plus réaliste possible c'est
pour ça qu'ils sont allés sur place pour
retourner dans les vrais décors dans un
souci de précision bien sûr ils ont pas
été sur place ils ont été sur place mais
n'importe quoi ils ont tourné dans le
désert de Wadie Rome en Jordanie je te
dis qu'ils ont été sur place le film
raconte l'histoire d'un équipage en
mission sur Mars qui va devoir repartir
en catastrophe à la suite d'une grosse
tempête sauf qu'il y en a un qui va se
prendre un truc dans la gueule du coup
les autres vont penser qu'il est mort et
ils vont partir sans lui sauf qu'en fait
il n'est pas mort il va se retrouver
seul sur Mars c'est un truc de ouf il
deviendra le le premier homme à se
retrouver seul sur une planète entière
et partout il ira sur Mars il sera le
premier et il va devoir survivre jusqu'à
l'arrivée de la prochaine mission 4 ans
plus tard en cultivant des pommes de
terre sur le sol martien ou normalement
rien ne peut pousser parce que le seul
martien c'est pas de la terre comme sur
terre c'est du regolith c'est-à-dire
c'est de la si vous voulez c'est de la
c'est les canaux hein voilà si c'est de
la poussière c'est la roche hein voilà
c'est de la merde tu ne fais rien
pousser là-dedans alors si en fait tu
peux tu peux pas si si je t'assure on
peut
en mettant de la merde partout pour
fertiliser le sol avec la bactéries bah
en gros ouais alors écoute on peut pas
chier comme ça partout ouais on peut pas
chier sur tous les trucs qu'on voit
juste pour faire les expériences
scientifiques ah bah si moi je fais tout
le temps et ça marche
sinon puisque tu es là ma chère
Valentine c'est quoi le regolith c'est
une maladie de quand tu rigoles trop en
fait tu as une rigolite en vrai c'est
surtout la couche de poussière et autres
cailloux solitaire qui recouvrent la
surface de Mars et des autres corps
rocheux en général c'est un peu
l'épiderme de la planète enfin c'est
surtout une victimes parce que en
surface la roche se fait bolosse par
l'atmosphère l'hydrosphère s'il y a un
cycle de l'eau ce qui est le cas sur
Mars même si on cherche encore le
liquide et la biosphère s'il y a de la
vie a priori pas de vie actuelle sur
Mars mais peut-être qu'il y en aurait eu
dans le passé donc peut-être il aurait
pu foncer dans la mêlée la chute de
météorites tout ça ça va abîmer la roche
mère et la broyer en plus ou moins
petits morceaux mais il y a pas que
l'érosion physique il y a aussi
l'empoisonnement puisque la roche peut
être altérée par l'atmosphère ou par
l'eau qui lui tombe sur la mouille bon
clairement la roche perd toujours la
bataille à force de se faire bouler elle
va développer une couche de bleu sur
toute la surface de son corps sauf
qu'ils sont pas littéralement bleus
c'est plus un tas de cailloux plus ou
moins gros qui forme comme un embryon de
sol de sol pas du tout fertile en
l'occurrence ok bon très bien expliqué
merci beaucoup et ben gros bisous ma
Valou gros bisous mon Yanou ah bah ouais
bah j'y vais la chaîne science de
comptoir c'est un petit peu ma six sur
Youtube quoi allez vite vous abonner à
sa chaîne et donc effectivement Mark
wattney va y arriver grâce à quoi de la
merde et ouais il va se servir du caca
de toute l'équipe pour fertiliser le sol
il va devenir une sorte de et il va
surtout devenir le meilleur botaniste de
la planète aussi facile et tout seul et
du coup il va bouffer des patates c'est
pas compliqué le mec ne bouffe que des
pommes de terre pendant deux heures il
en mange là il en mange là là aussi là
encore
oublié ah bah le film aurait pu
s'appeler seul sur Mars
existentiels mais ça c'est une semaine
que j'ai plus cette boutique ketchup je
vous ai dit c'est de la harpe science on
retrouve un casting 5 étoiles avec Matt
Damon dans le rôle principal de Mark
wattney qui doit encore une fois être
sauvé il fallait déjà aller le chercher
le bout de la galaxie dans interstellar
et il fallait aussi aller le sauver dans
Il faut sauver le soldat Ryan et non
c'est bon quoi je veux dire un moment
donné ce qu'il veut pas se démerder un
peu tout seul aussi quoi au prix on le
paye en fait ça aurait pu s'appeler il
faut sauver l'astronaute Whitney quelque
part
on retrouve aussi dans l'équipe de
l'astronautes Jessica Chastain qui joue
la capitaine toujours aussi magnifique
oh là là ah Jessica c'est pour est-il
que mon cerveau soit troublé par
quelques pensées impurs non c'est pas
possible alors moi je suis toujours
focus Sébastien Stan le soldat de
l'hiver Marvel toujours aussi haute je
ressemble un peu non toi il y a pas tu
es un petit truc vous imaginez comment
je serai beau gosse et je faisais du un
régime du sport aussi comme ça je vais
pas le faire mais vous imaginez Michael
pega j'aime beaucoup cet acteur aussi je
l'avais adoré dans Crash kate Mara la
sœur de rounetra et la NASA on a un
grand patron je jouais pas tube Daniel's
j’arriverai jamais à me sortir de la
tête de mon Dumber à chaque fois que je
le vois lui chiotel et Jo fort qui était
incroyable dans twelzer the slave un
film fort un film
en film juste
un film juste non non
non je suis pas raciste du tout ok que
ce soit clair le racisme c'est pour les
connards et les connards c'est les
Arabes Sean Bean qu'on me présente plus
qui est steinwig Benedict Wong a habitué
des films de science-fiction puisqu'on a
déjà vu dans Sunshine Prometheus c'est
bien sûr dans les films Marvel Donald
Glover et d'autres encore ça c'est du
test un jeu alors seul sur Mars c'est un
film scientifique d'un film avec des
scientifiques qui font de la science ça
te parle d'hydrogène d'oxygène de
polymétaquillette de méthyle je me
rappelle pas du tout qui dit ça non mais
celui-là il en parle pas mais ils
auraient très bien pu il te crée de
l'eau ils te font pousser des plans qui
pirates des satellites ils inventent des
systèmes de communication avec ce film
tu fais plus de science en deux heures
et demie que pendant tout ton cursus
scolaire et quand tu ressors de la salle
et ben tu as rien compris exactement
comme pendant ton cursus scolaire c'est
un film tellement scientifique que les
scientifiques eux-mêmes écrivent science
sur leur tableau de calcul ah non mais
là on attend des niveaux mon gars c'est
un film à la gloire de la science bah
parce que ça qui marche Marc wattney il
a pas survécu en priant et en espérant
alors après tout le problème du film si
je puis m'exprimer ainsi tiens sur le
fait que il se veut le plus réaliste
possible et dans les grandes lignes il y
arrive mais qui bave tout son intrigue
sur un élément qui t'en absolu et lui
impossible une violente tempête de sable
qui renverse leur vaisseau parce que si
vous voulez il y a un truc qu'il faut
savoir à propos de mars c'est que son
atmosphère est 75 fois moins dense que
l'atmosphère terrienne alors parmi tout
ce que ça voudrait dire et bah ça veut
notamment dire qu'un vent martien pour
qu'il exerce la même force qu'un moment
que terrestre il faudra qu'il soit
je me promène pareil bon sur Mars c'est
très bien représenté ça va oui regardez
là pendant la même donné bon on va fobo
c'est dans les ciel comme Phobos je sais
pas pourquoi je parle comme ça faut
bosser le plus grand des deux satellites
de Marseille de n'importe quoi de mars
bah ouais c'est pour ça
et d'ailleurs vous voyez aussi ce rocher
là et ça on s'en fout donc ça va c'est
cool sauf pour quelques détails par
exemple le soleil dans le ciel il
devrait être moins brillant que ça mars
à l'école 1,6 fois plus loin du soleil
que nous ce qui veut dire d'après un
rapide calcul que j'ai fait de tête que
normalement on devrait le voir trois
fois plus faible dans le ciel de mars
qu'on le voit sur terre mais bon hein
tout ça
exactement au final c'est quand même un
film très bien documenté il y a assez
peu d'erreurs scientifiques bon le
vaisseau Hermès qui utilise il est
vraiment balèze les premières missions
habitées vers Mars normalement vers 2035
c'est ce qu'annonce à NASA on aura pas
d'aimer soit comme ça mais dans
l'ensemble la communauté scientifique
internationale a très bien reçu le film
allez on est parti on est chaud on lance
le film et c'est reparti avec encore un
film qui commence avec un ciel étoilé
bordel je sais pas combien de films
commencent comme ça sérieux rien que
dans ce dont j'ai parlé sur ma chaîne il
y en a au moins un million et le titre
arrive direct de motion ça c'est joli
moi je kiffe en mode alien là avec les
lettres du titre qui disparaissent aussi
dans l'espace vous croyez que c'est une
référence mais
nous voici sur Mars et voilà c'est beau
hein c'est beau c'est c'est des heures
si voilà c'est nul c'est nul voyons on
peut le dire bah c'est mars quoi c'est
rien de particulier à y foutent bah
c'est vrai non mais moi aujourd'hui tu
me poses la question cette vie elle est
sur Mars non tu n'es rien à [__]
là-bas parce que je peux aller en
Jordanie ce sera pareil de toute façon
même en Jordanie tu te fais chier alors
sur Mars je préfère passer du temps avec
mon fils c'est d'ailleurs exactement ce
que disait Alexandre Astier en parlant
de ses gosses je préfère gagner une
heure de vie avec eux que de me barrer
sur Mars donc là on découvre toute
l'équipe de la mission arest3 Arès vous
savez le nom du dieu grec de la guerre
et son équivalent romain est mars et oui
nous on prend des trucs et ils sont en
train de faire des des voilà ils font
des trucs scientifiques quoi on sait
jamais ce qu'ils foutent encore des
trucs qui coûtent des milliards et qui
servent très certainement à rien il y a
une bonne ambiance d'Evan
enfin trouvé de l'eau liquide bordel
mais on s'en fout plein dans la base on
n'a pas besoin de celle-là ah oui c'est
et en fait il raconte tellement de
conneries que le capitaine mais elle dit
il y en a qui gère la communication de
leur couper carrément leur micro et bam
genre là elle leur a coupé le micro le
truc à peine dangereux le gars il a un
problème de température de pression
d'oxygène il peut alerter personne quoi
bravo première connerie et évidemment
c'est une meuf qui l'a fait en même
temps les rousses oui bah ça part très
mal bon voilà direct il y a une alerte
tempête la nana dit à tout le monde de
rentrer mais la capitaine s'en fout et
dit j'ai vu ça au dressing ce matin on
sera rentré avant qu'elle arrive voilà
deuxième connerie on en est à 5 minutes
du film il dure 2h30 et on n'est pas
sorti du sable et eux non plus
voilà la tempête elle est quand même
plus grosse que prévu donc au final le
capitaine dit qu'ils doivent se barrer
il faut qu'ils ressortent pour récupérer
plein de matos mais la tempête est déjà
là il s'engouffre dedans il fait noir il
y a des résidus partout titre et là le
vent est tellement fort qu'un truc se
décroche et pas Whitney se fait exploser
la gueule et gicle à 30 mètres plus loin
c'est grave chaud là si ça se trouve il
est mort direct et en plus ils ont perdu
le signal maintenant il va falloir le
retrouver mais dans la tempête c'est
impossible il ne le retrouveront pas
surtout que pendant ce temps-là le
vaisseau est sur le point de se
renverser et après pour décoller ça va
être moins pratique et donc ils doivent
prendre la lourde décision de se barrer
sans lui il foute le camp il le laisse
tomber ça c'est les américains ils
allument les propulseurs et ils décolle
avec le siège de wattney vide puisqu'il
n'est pas là c'est logique mais c'est
hyper scientifique le film un mec n'est
pas là son siège est vide régler Scott
c'est hyper bien renseigné il y a eu des
consultants et tout et du coup ça veut
dire que s'il est pas là forcément son
siège à vide du coup voyons c'est ça et
du coup on découvre sur terre le
directeur de la NASA alors lui je le
sens pas il nous annonce que ça va tout
s'est bien passé bon je pense que ça va
tout s'est bien passé on a une petite
tempête qui nous oblige à repartir et on
a paumé un astronaute on s'est pas où il
est donc on l'a laissé non je déconne en
fait il est mort et ouais l'info est
rendu public l'astronaute Marc wattney
est mort sauf que non il n'est pas mort
et ouais truc de ouf il a survécu il se
réveille pile au moment où il y a plus
d'oxygène dis donc comme par hasard et
bien voulu par contre ce jour parce
qu'il a un truc planté dans le bide il
rentre à la base était leur Rambo qui
n'a peur de rien et qui est ultra badass
il va se soigner tout seul et faire face
à la douleur comme un homme pour
recevoir ce bon moi tu me dis épine là
tu es astronaute tout est danseuse
étoile et là il va enregistrer un
message dans une sorte de carnet de bord
dans lequel il dit qu'il est vivant mais
qu'il a aucun moyen de contacter la NASA
et que de toute façon même s'il y
arrivait il devrait patienter 4 ans
jusqu'à ce que la prochaine mission
habitait ce positive en plus s'échange
de survie sont très minimes parce que
tous les équipements pour répéter à
n'importe quel moment et que si tout
tient le coup c'est lui qui au final
viendra pas le coup parce qu'il y a un
moment donné où il va finir par mourir
de faim en résumé mon Marco tu es dans
la merde
sauf que non non pas ouais Marc wattney
est dans la mouise mais il ne va pas y
rester je crèverai pas ici et ouais il
est motivé il va survivre il crèvera pas
sur Mars pas comme ça non pas comme ça
allez c'est parti fais l'inventaire de
la bouffe il va faire sa crotte c'est
marrant il y a les codes barres le tout
l'équipage sur les chiottes mais ça sert
à quoi ce truc là il faut se scanner
quand tu vas démouler ton cake c'est
pour savoir qui est bouché la cuvette ou
qui est [__] et les murs n'empêche
c'est intéressant peut-être en mettre de
ça chez moi en même temps ça servira à
rien et on sait déjà que c'est moi à
chaque fois et là c'est en tirant la
chasse qu'il a d'un seul coup une idée
et si au lieu de tirer la chasse il
mangeait sa merde hé c'est peut-être pas
une mauvaise idée comme ça ça fait
circuit fermé et illimité tu vois là il
ouvre un autre placard et il voit des
patates et ça c'est génial parce qu'il
va pouvoir les manger mais il a un
problème de taille c'est qu'il n'a pas
de Willy il pourra pas bien éplucher ses
patates et là il se rend compte qu'il a
quand même assez de bouffe pour tenir un
petit peu de temps et qu'il faut
simplement qu'il trouve un moyen de
cultiver assez de nourriture pour 4 ans
sur une planète ou rien ne pousse et par
chance je suis botaniste
donc là qu'est-ce qu'il va faire et ben
il va se créer son propre potager à
l'intérieur de la station il va choper
de la terre qui n'est donc pas de la
terre mais du regolithe comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure où tu fais rien pousser
là-dedans il y a rien d'organique mais
what Ness c'est qu'en mettant des
déchets biologiques les comprenait de la
merde et ben tu peux arriver à
fertiliser le sol ça fait de l'engrais
ma poule et ouais attends faut être
sorti pour savoir ça il va donc pouvoir
faire pousser les trucs sur Mars mars je
t'emmerde et voilà bien dit il fait une
petite purée de merde il en met dans le
sol il met la pomme de terre dans la
merde et il va se faire une petite
salade de patates sauce caca c'est très
goûtu ça du retour moi j'en ai fait une
on va le présenter à Top Chef la semaine
prochaine on a toutes nos chances bon
après c'est pas tout je veux dire ça
c'est bien mais il faut de l'eau aussi
et la marque watner va se transformer en
Marc Gyver et va réussir à faire de
l'eau à partir de nos formules simples
que tout le monde connaît t'ajoutes de
l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène et tu brûles
et voilà c'est tout vraiment pas
compliqué tu fais un petit feu tu le
place doucement tout doucement dans le
truc là tu amènes l'hydrogène et hop bah
le travail vraiment aussi facile
ah bon il y a rien dit mais en fait la
science c'est pas si facile que ça c'est
pour ça que j'en ai jamais fait moi j'en
ai fait juste assez pour avoir deux au
bacs en maths j'ai déjà dit je sais mais
bon ça m'a marqué mais je crois en plus
qui donnait déjà un point et demi pour
la présence bon donc voilà les jours
passent ils se comptent en sol vous avez
vu il y a écrit seul à chaque fois là
parce qu'en fait il compte un jour
soleil à pas confondre avec le jour
sidéral en général on compte un jour
soleil c'est le temps que met le soleil
entre deux zénithes entre midi et puis
midi du lendemain c'est un jour solaire
et ça ça dure 24 heures sauf que
techniquement la terre elle ne tourne
pas sur elle-même en 24 heures elle ne
met que 23 heures 56 minutes et 4
secondes donc 3 minutes et 56 secondes
de moins et ça c'est le jour sidéral
mais alors dites-moi pourquoi quand on
fait une différence entre les deux nous
ce qui nous intéresse c'est la planète
qui fait un tour complet sur elle-même
donc 23h56 buts et 4 secondes plus
emmerdez ou 24 heures là oui sauf que
pendant que la terre est tournée sur
elle-même elle a aussi bougé sur son
orbite elle tourne autour du soleil il
me semble-t-il elle s'est déplacée
d'environ 1 degré sur l'orbite donc
quand elle aura fait un tour sur
elle-même en 23h564 secondes le soleil
il sera plus exactement la même place
dans le faudra encore que la terre
tourne un tout petit studio plus et on
retrouve le soleil au même endroit
seulement 3 minutes 56 plus tard et on
retombe selon 24 heures et ça c'est un
jour solaire si on se base sur la
position du soleil dans le ciel et Marco
lui pendant ce temps-là et ben il a
réussi à créer de la condensation et
ouais ça marche jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive
au sol 54 et là petite note de piano là
oh le titre mimine elle a poussé ça a
marché bordel de dieu salut toi comment
il dit l'expression salut toi on a
l'impression qu'il va gagner la feuille
alors là il y a le directeur des
missions martiennes qui arrivent il a
l'air un peu vénère c'est plus
comprendre et il va voir le directeur de
la NASA on dit de voir qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour Marc wattnell c'est à dire bah
on va quand même pas le laisser là-bas
faut aller le chercher quoi bah oui faut
rapatrier le corps on peut pas laisser
pourrir là-bas rapatrier mais il est fou
vous savez comment ça coûte ben je sais
bien mais bon la famille elle demande
mais qu'est-ce que j'en ai à [__] de
sa famille moi ce genre de question il
est mort c'est tout on filera son nom
une décharge publique et puis c'est
marrant voilà donc on attendra la
prochaine mission à rescat pour
rapatrier le corps si jamais on le
retrouve pendant ce temps-là mais je
suis en contrôle et des dizaines d'écran
avec un milliard d'informations là qui
servent à rien en plus que du foie trop
petit on peut rien lire et là il y a une
petite nana qui remarque un truc sur les
images satellites du site de la base
martienne que personne n'a vu il y a un
truc qui a bougé entre le jour 18 et le
jour 54 elle appelle tout le monde le
directeur la NASA la directeur des
missions martiennes responsable de la
communication et il est réalise que
Whitney est toujours vivant de Dieu et
là on se rend compte ce n'est pas déjà
remarqué que lui là lui il a c'est quand
même un sale petit [__] toute façon
si les calculs sont exactement bien
avant qu'on puisse lui venir en aide
mais quelle espèce de [__] sérieux j'y
crois pas vous rendez compte ah il
manque pas d'air le [__] aimer en
même temps il a un petit peu raison bah
uber qu'est-ce que tu as fait tu as
envoyé une autre mission qui va prendre
je sais pas combien de temps et qui va
coûter je sais pas combien de milliards
juste pour essayer de sauver un type non
non non on fait pas ça non il est là-bas
il reste et puis tant pis
exactement c'est Drago qui a raison bah
ils sont quand même obligé de faire un
petit communiqué donc bah à tout le
monde est au courant quel moyen
avez-vous employés pour communiquer avec
Marc
watnerait arriver dans 5000 ans sur Mars
marques contenu de faire des calculs de
toute façon il a que ça à [__] non
mais je sais pas moi j'ai ferais du
sport tu vois j'essaierai de faire de la
gonflette cool l'autre il peut son temps
à faire les opérations des racines
carrées là il fait même des rosaces avec
son compas là c'est vraiment dire si il
se fait chier et calcule aussi qui va
lui falloir 50 jours pour rejoindre le
cratère le scaparelli qui se trouve à
3200 km d'ici enfin bref cratère qui
existe hein sur Mars ils ont pas pris
n'importe quel nom évidemment parce que
c'est là que la prochaine mission
arescade va atterrir quatre ans plus
tard ils reviennent pas exactement et là
ils vont ailleurs il va donc devoir
passer 50 jours pour faire 3200 km dans
un petit Rover qui au départ conçu pour
en faire que 35 voilà on est pas
qui gère un peu tous les astronautes dit
qu'il faut qu'il le sachent parce que
Boromir il est loyal tu vois c'est un
mec bien il a jamais trahi personne
voler d'un autre frelon oui mais il
s'est racheté après on s'en fout il est
génial c'était un héros là comme son
frère là l'autre merde de faire Amir qui
sert à rien là mais ta gueule toi et
casse-toi va te marier avec Owen sert à
rien non plus ah vous êtes bien trouvé
tous les deux sur Mars bah ça y est les
premières potatoes elles ont poussé il
va pouvoir se faire des bons rusties des
pommes de terre martiennes naturelles
100% bio pas grave elles sont cultivées
au caca si ça c'est pas du bio mon pote
je sais pas ce que c'est et là il a un
flash parce que le problème c'est que
pour le moment il a toujours pas réussi
à contacter la terre il a pas moyen de
communication sauf que là il en a trouvé
un l'ancienne sonde spatiale passe
Finder qui avait été envoyé en 97 ça
fait 38 ans qu'elle est là et qu'elle
fonctionne plus donc là si tu veux
falloir un miracle pour que ça marche et
ça tombe bien on est au cinéma sur terre
ils comprennent que Whitney elle est
chopée pasfender donc il ressortent la
réplique pour communiquer avec Marco
branche une nouvelle batterie tout
l'antenne vers la terre il le voit la
terre là on la voit dans le ciel là ça
c'est trippon c'est la terre il allume
et bingo ça marche il va enfin pouvoir
continuer à envoyer des riles insta à
ses potes
sauf évidemment à chaque fois qu'il y a
une solution il y a un nouveau problème
sur la sonde il y a qu'une seule caméra
qui peut bouger à 360 degrés mais il y a
pas de micro donc lui qu'est-ce qu'il
peut faire bah il peut poser des
questions et les autres peuvent diriger
la caméra vers un panneau oui ou non en
sachant qu'il y a toujours un délai de
32 minutes entre chaque mouvement donc
si tu veux pour tenir une discussion
complexe à base d'information et de
calcul de ouf ça va prendre des mois
quoi il faut donc trouver une solution
plus efficace pour communiquer comme
disait Copernic que faire
je dois élaborer un alphabet et ouais
rien que ça et là tu te rends compte que
l'astronautes ils ont oublié d'être con
bah attends 22000 candidats pour 17
postes chaque année là je peux te dire
que ils prennent les meilleurs des
meilleurs des meilleurs le mec va
carrément inventer un alphabet quoi truc
de ouf alors 8 ah non ça c'est un
chiffre il faut une lettre
12 et là il va utiliser ce qu'on appelle
un système hexadécimal c'est extrêmement
facile à comprendre c'est un système en
bas 16 hexa 6 décimal 10 + 6 16 et qui
utilise les chiffres de 1 à 9 et les
lettres de A à F et qui qui permet donc
si vous voulez de voilà de communiquer
de qui permet de faire des
communications je sais pas comment ça
marche en fait mais si je sais comment
ça marche mais je sais très bien mais
voilà c'est pas facile à expliquer
si vous voulez non mais je vais vous
mettre un lien en description ce sera
plus facile pour tout le monde ou
retenez install des panneaux autour du
rover les autres sur terre ils font même
vous avez vu la Whitney il marche sur
Mars comme s'il marchait sur Terre on a
toujours l'impression que la gravité est
exactement la même dans le film et même
mouvement que la même vitesse quand il
un truc par terre c'est la même chose
bah oui mais normalement ça devrait pas
du tout être comme ça pourquoi mais la
gravité sur Mars c'est pas la même que
la taille il me semble que ça devrait
jouer un petit peu sur les mouvements
comme par exemple dans Armageddon quand
ils sont sur l'astéroïde et quand Harry
chope la carotte bon les voix flotter un
peu dans les airs comme ça eux au moins
ils ont respecté le truc [__] attendez
la vache est-ce que ça veut dire que
ramageddon je respecterai mieux la
réalité physique que celle sur Mars
alors ben j'ai rien dit bref grâce à ça
ils arrivent à expliquer à Marc comment
pirater page Finder pour le connecter au
Rover pour pouvoir communiquer encore
mieux cette fois par textes de ou je
sais pas comment ils ont fait on a rien
compris ils ont fout c'est pas le
problème et là ils peuvent enfin
communiquer normalement et Marc voit
tout de suite demander comment son
équipe a réagi quand ils ont appris
qu'il était encore en vie sauf que la
NASA il l'aura pas encore dit ces petits
bateaux donc quand il lui avoue Marc et
Lucine complètement et il dit [__] de
bordel de merde vous êtes tous cinglé
c'est vraiment ça qui leur écrit à tes
mots pour mot lettre pour lettre le
problème c'est que tout ce qu'il dit est
directement retranscrit dans le monde
entier parce que tous les gens sont
comme ça donc les mecs lui disent de pas
écrire trop de conneries quoi et ben
niquez vos morts et elle est tous vous
faire cuire le cube bande de sa caméra
fini la piste vous chie dans la gueule
il abuse un peu quand même il va un peu
loin mais bon en même temps les autres
aussi ils abusent sérieux ils ont rien
dit à l'équipage moi j'aurais dit pareil
que lui voire pire ah ben j'aurais dit
bande de gros donc
du coup il est vraiment temps de les
prévenir et voici le vaisseau Hermès
nommé d'après le dieu grec Hermès a un
messager des dieux dieu des voyageurs et
des micro pénis et son équivalent romain
est mercure et ouais non mais il y a un
sens à tout ça aussi oublier d'être con
vous croyez quoi vous croyez qu'on fait
tous ça comme ça par hasard et lui le
vaisseau il est classe avec son module
qui tourne là franchement c'est beau
pourquoi ils ont fait ça mais c'est
vraiment artificielle
parce que on a vachement souvent vu dans
des films de science-fiction des
vaisseaux spatiaux humains avec des
modules qui tournent comme ça pour
recréer une gravité artificielle on l'a
vu dans 2001 dans interstellar dans
Avatar et encore dans plein d'autres
films mais en fait ça on l'a encore
jamais construit on sait pas le faire ça
en fait enfin je sais pas si on sait le
faire ou pas mais en tout cas
actuellement c'est encore des structures
qui sont beaucoup trop grandes pour
qu'on puisse le faire en théorie ça
marcherait mais on a encore jamais
essayé et donc boromi renvoie un message
à l'équipage Marc wattney est toujours
en vie mais c'est qui marque mais ta
gueule et vous savez c'est celui que
vous avez lâchement abandonné comme des
chiens avec vous êtes là ouais et toi la
chienne un chienne espèce de chienne ça
va chier c'est bon dites-leur là oui bah
qui est vivant et oui il est vivant il
est vivant alors là la NASA décide
d'envoyer un conteneur de bouffe sur
Mars pour que Whitney bah tienne un peu
le coup tu vois on lui envoie quoi on
accueillant envoyer des mars c'était
pour la blague tu es viré Jacky le
directeur de la NASA demande si ce sera
prêt à temps c'est un peu serré mais ça
va le faire titre Marc lui bah il rentre
chez lui après une bonne journée de
travail et là
gros
et oui il y a eu un problème de
dépressurisation dans le sas d'entrée le
couloir qui lui sert à rejoindre son
champ là donc voilà bah maintenant tout
est joli bah oui mais quand il fait
moins 120 dehors et que tu as laissé la
porte ouverte là tout le chauffage se
barre en tout cas là c'est le tournant
du film parce qu'il vient de perdre sa
seule source de nourriture alors du coup
pour réparer le trou bah il met une
bâche voilà une petite machette voilà
puis mets du scotch un peu tout autour
pour que ça tienne et il espère qu'avec
ça il va réussir à repassurer le module
alors question est-ce que cette manœuvre
est réaliste non pas du tout c'est même
a priori du grand n'importe quoi ils ont
pas fait beaucoup de grosses conneries
niveau réalisme scientifique mais
celle-là s'en est une belle Alain
Souchier hein qui était un ingénieur
aérospatial très reconnu un spécialiste
de l'exploration martienne il avait fait
des calculs il avait trouvé que la
poussée serait de entre 20 et 30 tonnes
sur la bâche c'est-à-dire vous prenez un
truc qui fait 30 tonnes voilà vous ne
pouvez pas vous poser 6 éléphants aussi
gros éléphants d'Afrique sur la vache et
elle est censée tenir juste avec du
scotch comme ça et bien c'est un nom
négatif monsieur Scott bon on s'en fout
il fait l'inventaire de ce qui c'est à
dire pas grand chose il informe la terre
et du coup ça change tous les plans ils
ont plus du tout à cet temps pour lui
envoyer la bouffe ils doivent trouver
une autre solution et pour ça ils vont
chercher l'un des meilleurs pilotes de
la galaxie le propriétaire du Faucon
Millenium avant qu'il n'atterrissent
dans les mains de Han Solo son meilleur
ami j'ai nommé landau calertion ouais il
est là il est planqué sur terre il bosse
dans l'aérodynamique évidemment et lui
il va bûcher sur une nouvelle solution 4
semaines plus tard le module avec les
livres est prêt à décollé parce qu'ils
vont quand même essayer d'en envoyer un
au cas où en fait on sait jamais ils
vont quand même le faire tous les
calculs ont été faits on y va voyant
Dieu Vincent
alors
ok donc là on a les mecs les plus
scientifiques et les plus terre à terre
de la terre qui savent parfaitement que
les croyances nées dans rien dans ce
genre de situation mais qui sont quand
même capables de sortir le truc comme ça
il y a quelque chose qui m'échappe de
toute façon les dieux aussi il y a
quelque chose qui leur échappe parce que
la fusée elle
explose le lancement tout ça parce que
le directeur il a dit aux équipes de pas
faire des tests pour gagner du temps
résultat on en perd encore plus ah bah
là lui il doit se dire
c'est clair Dieu a gâché un bon trou du
cul quand il lui a mis des dents dans la
bouche du coup Marc il leur demande si
le lancement s'est bien passé et l'autre
il leur répond que non mais ils ont eu
un très beau feu d'artifice ça c'était
super et ouais Marco là ça sent le
Roussillon mon gars comme disait Galilée
là ça pue la merde mais c'est comme ça
la vie c'est comme ça fait pas de cadeau
Lapi heureusement ça reste un film de
science-fiction dans lequel on voit des
choses qui ne sont pas possibles et là
on va peut-être en voir le meilleur
exemple les Chinois vont proposer leur
aide en prêtant leur fusée qui elle
fonctionne et la NASA va dire oui donc
là on va avoir les USA et la Chine qui
vont collaborer pour un projet spatial
mon pote si là on est pas au summum de
la science-fiction après redley Scott
perpendu que il faut quand même montrer
que les chinois c'est des connards on
entend beaucoup revenir dire aux Chinois
que c'est plus comme ça qu'on travaille
depuis longtemps c'est pas apollonaire
le message est quand même bien là on
veut bien travailler avec vous de toute
façon on pourra pas y arriver sans vous
mais vous êtes quand même démerdes et
c'est important que vous le sachiez la
NASA organise ensuite un meeting secret
avec eux et tête pensante et ce meeting
est baptisé projet aileronde alors Annie
la directrice de com elle comprend pas
pourquoi ça s'appelle el ronde et pour
revenir lui répond mais si c'est dans le
Seigneur des Anneaux là quand ils font
un conseil secret là pour détruire
l'Anneau mais quel rond il se fait
interrompre par Frodon parce que l'autre
il a la kyûle vous vous êtes rassemblés
ici afin de répondre à la menace du
Mordor
[Musique]
c'est des gros porcs et là Lando arrive
et va leur expliquer qu'il a trouvé une
solution pour renvoyer Hermès le
vaisseau de l'équipage qui doit revenir
sur Terre vers Mars plus vite que prévu
en passant par un trou noir il explique
ça carrément au directeur en personne ça
c'est ta mère ça c'est ma [__] en fait
il dit qu'on peut utiliser la force
gravitation de la terre pour recettes à
pulser à Metz à balvert mars ça
s'appelle l'assistance gravitationnelle
ça existe c'est une technique qu'on a
même déjà utilisé bon par contre ils
pourront pas atterrir sur Mars Hermès je
veux dire il y a plus assez de carburant
dans le petit module donc là il faudra
que Whitney trouve un moyen de décoller
de mars pour les rejoindre dans l'espace
pour les autres ils ont quand même plein
de questions est-ce qu'ils auront assez
de carburant est-ce qu'ils auront assez
d'oxygène est-ce qu'ils ont assez de PQ
est-ce qu'ils ont assez de capote mais
arrêtez de me poser toutes ces questions
en même temps on les a posé l'une après
l'autre si on les avait posées en même
temps ça aurait fait après le seul petit
truc c'est qu'il va falloir dire à
l'équipage d'Hermès que quand ils
arrivent bah en fait ils doivent tout de
suite repartir c'est leur ferait 533
jours à ajouter à la durée de leur
mission
la seule seconde oui bah il y en a un
qui va hésiter c'est le directeur parce
que s'il y a un truc qui foire là c'est
plus une personne qui meurt c'est 6 donc
il reste sur l'option d'envoyer juste
évident en attendant la prochaine
mission vous êtes vraiment à dégonfler
si Hitler c'est le péterne parce que la
team elle va pas se dégonfler ils vont
chercher leur faute on y va alright
beaches et on le mets poule c'est
reparti pour un tour et on se retrouve
directement cette fois plus tard Marc a
perdu 20 kilos et il a arrêté de se
raser il en a plus rien à [__] il se
prépare pour le décollage il laisse une
trace derrière lui titre il sera resté
461 jours sur Mars tout seul alors
qu'est-ce que ça dit là on est où non ah
il y a encore un problème cette fois il
se rend compte que l'Hermès ne pourra
pas se mettre en orbite tranquillement
autour de Mars parce que pour ça pour la
qui freine à balle donc il utilise gavé
de carburant et si ils font ça ils en
auront plus assez pour revenir c'est
bizarre qui se rend compte que
maintenant donc ils vont arriver très
vite et wattney va lui aussi de voir
arriver très vite pour qu'il puisse le
récupérer seulement sa capsule le VAM
elle est trop lourde il faut donc
l'alléger et pour ça où on gagne une
solution radicale enlever le toit je
voulais retirer la fin du vaisseau et il
va décoller avec un énorme trou dans son
vaisseau et on est plus après mais vous
inquiétez pas on va réutiliser notre
Bâche magique celle qui supporte 12
immeubles on va recouvrir le truc et ça
fera la rue Michel ouais je la sens de
temps celle-là mais en même temps
rappelez-vous l'atmosphère de Mars elle
est beaucoup plus fine que celle de la
Terre donc il y aura beaucoup moins de
frottements ça peut le faire ça peut le
faire il éjecte la porte le toit les
sièges le piano parenthèse des mini
tornades là il y en a plein pendant tout
le film on en voit souvent ça existe
aussi sur Mars bien sûr ils ont pas mis
ça au hasard on appelle ça les dust les
poussières du diable alors là sur terre
c'est carrément la folie tous les gens
sont descendus dans la rue pour suivre
en direct la mission de sauvetage genre
les gens en ont quelque chose à [__]
quoi alors bon d'accord j'ai bien croire
que c'est un événement un peu de ouf
mais bon là laisse tomber on se croirait
un concert de Mariah Carey ah je dis ça
parce que je suis déjà allé à Times
Square c'était pour un jour de l'an et
il y avait justement un concert gratuit
de Mariah Carey c'était ouf elle avait
une pure voix elle était là mais
handicapés c'est comme les lépreux et
les noirs allez les remettre ça arrive
le capitaine Lewis reparle pour la
première fois watni qui est un petit
poil en stress quand même on est sur le
toit je vous allez encaisser pas mal de
G ce serait normal que vous gagniez
connaissance titre allez c'est parti le
module décolle dites moi je suis pas le
seul à trouver que le truc ressemble à
une teub allez
ultime problème ils vont arriver encore
trop vite il faut donc qu'ils trouvent
un moyen de ralentir sans utiliser de
carburant et
ultime problème what name et pas aller
aussi loin que prévu et au point de
contact qui sera encore à 68 km du
vaisseau il faut donc encore trouver des
solutions d'urgence c'est ça que j'adore
dans ce film et là au grand mot les
grands remèdes ils vont tout simplement
construire une bombe et la faire péter
dans un dessin pour faire ralentir le
vaisseau et tout le monde trouve ça très
naturel non c'est pas naturel
non excuse-moi faire péter un truc dans
un vaisseau spatial c'est pas normal
allez on fait tout péter et Pam l’air
sort du module est fait freiner un peu
le vaisseau c'est bon ça a marché mais
what n'est toujours trop loin il se
trouve maintenant à 300 mètres du
vaisseau et il faut aller le chercher et
c'est bien sûr la capitaine qui s'y
colle attaché moi allez allez se jette
dans le vide mais malheureusement elle
est trop courte eh c'est dommage bon ben
on rentre alors allez salut bonne
continuation et bam il perd sa combi au
niveau de la main pour évacuer l'air et
se propulser en mode Iron Man il se
rapproche attention faut pas qu'il se
rate et ah là là là il arrête de très
peu mais il va quand même réussi à
choper la corde et ça y est elle arrive
à le récupérer ils ont réussi et c'est
pas trop tôt je crois qu'on peut le dire
aussi ça ils préviennent le QG qu'ils
ont réussi et
bah hier le monde entier heureux c'est
un truc de ouf [__] c'est dingue
comment j'en aurai rien à [__]
moi-même alors ils ont trouvé ça
maintenant enfin retrouver ses collègues
et voilà dernière scène on le retrouve à
nouveau sur Terre en train de savourer
un petit Moka glacé au chocolat blanc ah
mais il y a pas ça sur Mars et elle a
remarquez bien qu'on est le Day One le
premier jour de son retour sur terre
après être resté 549 sol martien donc en
gros 560 jours ce qui fait à peu près un
an et demi tout seul sur une autre
planète sans compter le voyage du retour
donc là on pourrait penser qu'il sera un
petit peu en droit de se reposer si tu
veux je sais pas peut-être aussi de voir
sa famille et qu'il a pas vu depuis plus
de 2 ans mais non day one il va tout de
suite fini des cours il bosse direct
sans transition tu as vu ça il décolle
pas la NASA pas le temps de niaiser et
là il leur raconte ce qu'il a retenu de
son incroyable expérience alors c'est
l'histoire d'un pingouin qui respire par
le cul un jour il s'assoit et il me et
fin et voilà tout ce que je pouvais vous
dire sur le film seul sur Mars the
Marchienne un bon film de Hard science
qui pourrait nous montrer des choses qui
pourraient peut-être arriver dans le
futur non ça arrivera pas en tout cas
j'espère pas parce que vivre pendant un
an et demi en cultivant des patates dans
sa merde moi rien que pour ça j'irai
jamais là-bas allez merci beaucoup à
toutes et à tous d'être toujours présent
d'être toujours fidèle à la religion 12
par 7 merci de prier votre Dieu
Ian solo je vous le rendrai je sais pas
quand ni comment mais je vous le rendrai
venez nous rejoindre sur les réseaux
sociaux venez dans le discord de 12 par
7 venez participer au live twitch c'est
tous les dimanches soir à 21h sauf qu'on
je peux pas il y a des rares fois où je
peux pas parce que je suis pas chez moi
mais en général c'est bon on est là et
on se marre bien allez jeter un coup
d’œil aussi sur le site novium les
stylos overpense sont vraiment
magnifiques et profiter des 10% de
réduction avec mon code faites-vous
plaisir allez c'est tout pour moi je
vous laisse je vous dis à très bientôt
pour un prochain épisode c'était game
solo sur 12 par 7 Ciao
[Musique]